翻訳: Hiroko Kawano
校正: Kyoko Kamura
皆さん この２つの缶
どちらがアルミ缶で どちらがスチール缶か
分かりますか？
缶の裏側を見ると
素材を確認できます
しかし 手に取ったり
マークを見たりしないと分かりません
私はこの空き缶を 自動で分別する
空き缶分別箱を
小学校５年生の夏休みの自由研究で発明し
2015年8月 日本では数少ない
特許を持つ小学生になりました
私の家では 誕生日にパパが
ケーキを作ってくれていました
手作りのケーキは めっちゃ美味しくて
とても嬉しかったです
弟の２歳の誕生日に 私も作りたいと
初めて作ったケーキがこれです
小学校１年生の時でした
今では家族や友達に
色々な料理を作っています
たこ焼き炒飯や
ケーキをこんな風に
デコレーションしたりしました
工夫して作ることが大好きで
家族や友達が喜んでくれるのが嬉しいです
小学校５年生の夏休み
自由研究の宿題を何にしようかな？
と考えていたときに
おじいちゃんのことを思い出しました
スーパーを経営しているおじいちゃんは
いつもゴミ箱から
アルミ缶やスチール缶などを分別していて
大変だなと思っていました
なんとか簡単にできる方法はないかな？
と思い
自由研究で缶を分別するものを
作ってみようと決めました
アルミ缶とスチール缶を分けるのには
どうしよう？と考えていたときに
小学校３年生の
理科の実験を思い出しました
それは鉄やアルミの板を斜めにして
磁石をすべらせる実験でした
鉄の板は磁石がぴったりくっつくのに
アルミの板はピューンと 磁石が
すべり台みたいにすべるのが面白かったな
分別するのにはこれが使えると
ひらめきました
では 磁石を使って
どうすれば分別できるのか？
色々な仕組みを考えました
２つやってみたけれど
上手く行きませんでした
もやもやしながら
「ああもう疲れちゃったな」と
磁石を付けた定規で
このようにして遊んでいました
磁石を付けた定規にくっついた缶が
シュッと外れたのを見て
パパが「今の動き 面白いね」と言いました
それを聞いて「これだ！」と思い
ゴミ箱の仕組みをひらめきました
そしてその仕組みを使ってできたのが
このゴミ箱です
空き缶をここに入れて行きます
すると アルミ缶は
このように真下に落ちます
スチール缶は
このように右側に落ちます
もう一度見たいですか？
（拍手）
ではやってみます
アルミ缶です
次にスチール缶です
（拍手）
アルミ缶です
スチール缶です
（拍手）
皆さん 「どうしてスチール缶が
曲がりながら落ちて行くの？」
と不思議に思いましたか？
ここが一番実験を重ね
そして楽しかったところです
まずひらめいた仕組みを実験しました
スチール缶です
次にアルミ缶です
アルミ缶です
スチール缶です
このように
筒に入れたアルミ缶は真下に落ちますが
スチール缶は右側に落ちました
仕組みが成功したので
このようなゴミ箱を作りました
これで完成のはずでしたが
失敗してしまいました
実験よりも
投入口が磁石から遠かったので
スチール缶も真下に落ちてしまったのです
そこで投入口に
ペラペラした板を付けました
思い通り磁石の方に行ったのですが
今度はスチール缶が
磁石にくっついて止まってしまいました
そこで磁石の下に
ペラペラした板を付けました
投入口に付けた
ペラペラした板の切れ端です
そして成功しました
スチール缶は
右側に落ちるようになりました
さらに精度を上げるため
最後に付けたペラペラした板の
長さを実験しました
１cmから５cmまで試してみたところ
３cmが一番ちょうど良いことが
分かりました
以前 特許を取ったことのあるパパが
ゴミ箱を見て
動きが面白くてシンプルなのが良いと思い
「明日香もどう？」と勧めてくれて
特許を申請することになりました
正直その時 私は
特許の意味もよく分かっていませんでした
夏休み中に 自由研究を終わらせないと
と焦った時もありましたが
思いついたアイディアは全部やりました
特許が取れたポイントとなった
ペラペラした板もそうです
できなくてもやってみる
これが上手く行かなくても
分かることがある
とにかくやってみる！
やりゃあなんとかなる！
そうして このゴミ箱は
夏休みが終わる５日前に完成しました
このゴミ箱は思いついてから
すぐにできた訳ではありません
私の思いとひらめきを
家族が協力して
一緒に形にしてくれたので
できました
思いついたらママに言って
ひらめきを頭の中で はっきりさせました
次にパパと一緒に試作を作ったり
失敗した時に
アイディアを出し合ったりして
形にして行きました
私は いつも協力してくれる
家族が大好きです
こうして私は特許を持つ
小さな発明者になりました
きっかけは 大好きな
家族や友達の中にあります
ひらめきは 遊びの中にあります
成功はあきらめた頃にやって来ます
そして皆さん
ひらめいたら 失敗を恐れず
とにかくやってみる
これが一番大切なことだと思います
（拍手）